[موسيقى]
تتواصل عروض افلام مهرجان كان السينما
الدولي بدورته 76 بسينما تحمل محتوى سينما
المؤلف والجوانب الانسانيه وبجماليات
سينمائيات مختلفه
ومنها الفيلم الياباني وحش او حيث نتعرف
على عمق المجتمعات الكبرى من خلال يوميات
الطلبه والافكار الحديثه على مجتمعات
المدينه
يبحث شخصيات في مونستر عن علاقات طارئه
وجديده وبنيه مكونه من ثلاثه اجزاء تسمح
للمشاهد بالمشاركه والتفاعل فيلم بلاك
فلاي او الطيور السوداء للمخرج الامريكي
جون ستيف والبطوله لشون بين
ويناق جوانب الانسانيه لعامل في الاطفاء
يواجه مشاكل حياتيه
فيلم فرنسي يحمل عنوان العوده للمخرج
الشابه كاترين يتحدث عن عمق المشاكل
الاجتماعيه بعد الطلاق وتبعثر العائله بعد
محاوله العوده الى مارسيليا والعوده الى
الحياه الطبيعيه فيها
ربما هناك شيء يذهلني ايضا في السينما وهو
اننا نفتقر الى التنوع وهو شيء اعمل عليه
في ضواحي المدن
فيلم صيني يحمل عنوان شباب للمخرج ونج في
المسابقه الرسميه عوالم الصين في المصانع
المتوسطه ومنها نتعرف على علاقات بين
العاملات في مصنع للخياطه ويوميات المدن
الصناعيه التي تنغى نصف العمل على حساب
انحدار العلاقات الاجتماعيه تنافس افلام
المخرجين الشباب في الاسبوع الاول بعد
عرضها في المهرجان واللجنه التحكيميه
تنتظر افلام كبار رواد السينما التي تم
برمجتها للاسبوع الثاني لعمر المهرجان سعد
المسعود العربيه مهرجان كان سينما الدولي
جنوب فرنسا
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات